what is like for people who don't know
what a manager does in a like a role
like yourself what is like your duties
as a manager like for people who are
interested in maybe getting into the
music industry or you know I think I
think that
the job description itself
has a few
kind of
unwavering core responsibilities for
everybody right no matter what client
you represent because it does vary right
every client needs of course of course
but managing relationships
managing relationships first and
foremost right you don't even have to
like your manager if you're doing your
job as an artist and your manager is
good at managing relationships you guys
can be extremely successful together
you know what I'm saying because that's
an artist it's like
you're the centerpiece like you're
you're the engine of the vehicle like
what you do determines if it goes or not
if your manager is good at managed
relationships people he's likeable he's
Dependable he's charismatic right he's
genuine he's friendly he does good
business by thinking about what the the
other
party is getting out of every equation
not just what you guys are getting so
that people see him as fair you guys can
be great together right that's first
second I think that your manager has to
have
if you're managing a this is a
difference right managing a rapper is
different if you're managing an artist
right
then I think that there has to be a
vision attached to it because
there has to be a long term
goal not just mere sighted
accomplishments right as the focus
when you think of rappers right and this
isn't to discredit anybody but this is
just like if this is just a fact
there's country artists pop artists
reggae artists
hip-hop artists
right right
when they say rappers it's kind of
because like rap is the evolution of
hip-hop it kind of created its own image
almost like its own genre it's like it
came kind of with the evolution of
production right so like
not necessarily baselines but like 808s
right and scent pads and different
things like that and then the concepts
in the subject matter of what rap talks
about hip-hop stems from like black and
brown people coming from like inner
cities in in just
places in America where your voices you
couldn't be heard right you didn't
finish certain political stature
economic stature so through break
dancing and graffiti and song form
people would listen now DJing parties DJ
yeah people listening but then rappers
the evolution that where it's like it
represents
black and brown people who have now
achieved those things that we didn't
have now now you have both now you have
money now you have a political stature
right so it's like we can talk about
different subject matters like cars and
Wealthy all these different glorified
things we never used to see Raps like
the evolution of hip-hop so I feel like
if you're managing rappers the landscape
of what that lifestyle entails you can
be in the clubs like you can do features
for money
and I love that [__] that's what I love
about how hip-hop has evolved to rap but
in some of the other genres the
traditional genres of like hip-hop
country Pop
um you know reggae r b whatever there
has to be kind of a more long-term goal
that's attached to it
because
those are not cash out genres like rap
has become right and that's why rap is
so saturated it's because there's enough
money in it to satisfy everybody well
yeah I think like core day I think he
had said like in one of our interviews
he turned down like
was it the Gap yeah he turned down like
a crazy bag didn't we tell you that
because I know you were fishing did we
say that oh I ended up saying yeah yeah
it was good yeah but like it's like not
all like I think it'd be corny well I
think most people like most artists or
rappers would be like how much is it yes
yeah yeah
I mean so I think that the
responsibility is coming out they're
just like having like a long-term vision
for where you guys want to go right
because now it's kind of going to serve
as a moral compass that allows you to
know what's right and wrong
for you for your business and for the
image of the artist
um again just focusing on like the long
term going not near sighted
accomplishments right and then I think
um
I think just like
yeah bro just
no one had only had to work cohesively
within a team right so your
representation of the artist so it's not
just managing relationships it's
understanding the functionality of teams
so if it's a label for example you gotta
know the difference between your a r
y'all know the difference between that
role and your product manager your admin
the Executive Vice President of a r
versus the ones who do research right
um your music video commissioner you
know um
the legal department
the president versus the CEO you know
versus
you know um because you're kind of like
first versus well you're also kind of
the liaison too between him and the
label right when it comes to certain
communication like yeah you kind of the
liaison between the artists and
everything yeah ultimately and that's
why it's so important for an artist and
a manager to be on the same page
just psychologically and also in terms
of like the orientation of your goals
because you're speaking on their behalf
if you guys aren't on the same page
you're gonna have a lot of false
narrative conversations on their behalf
and eventually those types of convos and
narratives get back to the artist and
that's what artists say wait why didn't
I know about this why didn't I yeah yeah
you didn't tell me this my managers
having conversations behind my back yeah
yeah I share all kinds of [__] yeah so
like when the conversations represent
the artist's best those conversations
never get back to the artist because
it's fluid right you know what I'm
saying like transparency is important
yeah and when something's wrong you know
like you know it's like a DJ and also an
entrepreneur and you know many other
things if you have relationships that
like little artists if you're talking to
their managers you know when it sounds
like it's coming from the manager not
the artist oh for sure it happens a lot
because the manager is not it's not
upholding the representation of the
artist that you know personally right so
when it's clear and it's concise
it feels consistent and it feels or
it'll feel like there'll be times I'll
be talking to like some guy's managers
and I'll be like dude
listen man
their Skies clearly putting the hole out
on top of whatever he's quoting me so he
can put it in his pocket right like it
happens and I think that's the other
thing too that would like to be real
with you like
again
rap is different because like it's just
such a lucrative industry where there's
so much money so yeah and it's a cash
heavy business so yeah yo I could tell
this promoter 25 and give my artist 20.
yeah for sure but when you're dealing
with almost any other genre they like
that you like that was just yeah that
was just happening with a big artist
who's a female
um where she found out that like
she was like whoever she was doing
parties with like I think it was her
Road manager which is like taken
yeah lots of bread off the top yeah and
I really do believe that like money is
what
focusing on money putting money first
right is what ruins businesses like you
have to focus on purpose yeah and long
and like like all that [__] will come it
does if as long as you don't put it
first right because at the end of the
day no one pays you money because you
want money right people pay you for a
service right or a byproduct that you're
selling so if you focus on the quality
of your service where people feel like
they either can't get it anywhere else
or that you just do it better than most
now the money will come in your life
that's what the the new Sun's owner just
made news because he uh
the sons have like a deal with like
Bally Sports for the last like five
years so if you didn't have cable you
can watch Sons games in Phoenix yeah and
he's like [__] that I want my [__] to be
free everywhere yeah so now the sun's
like you could watch like I think
starting next season
like wherever you're at you could either
stream Sons games for free you don't
have to have a league pass or if you're
in Arizona it's just on the [__]
normal channel three so like and he said
I just heard an interview he was like I
don't give a [__] he's like I give a
[__] about the fans he's like because
like the short-term money doesn't matter
like I'm gonna own this team forever
yeah another thing to remember to build
Die Hard fans I want the more people who
watch the game the more sense fans we
have like what are we doing here like
and the other thing to remember is right
like and I'll I'll draw a comparison in
lineage
with what I'm about to say even with
sports like you brought up the Suns
I'm a Celtics fan right go look at the
Celtics five years ago go get the sun
five years ago right look at any rapper
any hip-hop artist any pop artist just
any act go look at any corporate
business any brand it takes five years
to build a strong yeah an identifiable
business or brand yeah because five
years ago they uh they went to the
Eastern Conference Finals though go look
at what who the Celtics that was the
year that Kyrie was certain they went to
these in Conference Finals did we um
that was 2018. we went to Eastern
Conference Final yeah and lost to LeBron
James
right but but in any case go look at the
Players no no but nobody expected that
and it was kind of like a it felt like a
it felt like when the Hawks made it to
the Eastern Conference Finals two years
ago nobody was like well and also I
think no the Celtics have built is we
have a team that belongs to us now
though Kyrie was a traded player like no
no everybody's drafted everybody's
Marcus Smart Jason Tatum they took time
to develop those players for sure like
the whole Squad is it's been like Robert
Williams these are all people who were
like four years of Jason Tatum yeah
six or seven years ago everybody's like
what the [__] is Danny Haynes doing with
all these picks yeah and it worked out
yeah yeah Devin Booker like so my point
is like it's the same thing my artists
bro like even if you see like a success
that seems to just like come out of
nowhere like why be in the mirror like
like a a yeet or something like that
five years is going to tell you where
it's really at it's either gonna tail
off right because you didn't do the
Necessary Things Brick by Brick to make
sure that you were building something
sustainable or it's going to completely
start
to catapult and incline because you did
all of the groundwork to build something
sustainable now you're seeing the food
to your labor pay off so I think that as
a manager like you have to you have to
be focused on that because ain't nobody
bigger than the program right there's no
such thing as elevators they go up just
as fast as they come down yeah you got
to take the stairs because the only way
that you can fall off well literally
infinitively is if you choose to you got
to go back down those steps you have to
make terrible decisions on your behalf
that send you back down them but you
built it yourself
Brick by Brick so at least you have that
option I think that's like obviously
what you guys have been building with
core day it's like it's a fan base it's
a 20-year plan it's not a
you know [__] short-sighted I just
when I think according to be here and I
feel like he'll be here forever so it's
like you know a lot of these guys I
can't say that about yeah yeah the
hardest part for the artist I'm not sure
anyone's gonna care about Yeet in three
years I could be wrong I could be wrong
I'm this guy's crazy I just don't think
anyone's gonna care personally
seems like a nice I love you you know
what I like about your platform you get
to just say what the [__] you want I
mean shout out to you nobody can fire
you his music's [__] terrible but
it's someone likes it I like you know
what I like you know the thing that
somebody likes Yeet somebody likes
Playboy cardi all this [__] is just
going over my head under my head what I
think is super important too
you know he likes to eat he [__]
piece yeah yeah
oh this guy this guy's a [__] but you
know what I think this is super
important I think this is so important I
think this is the [__] reason why we
have so many trolls also because it's
like little white kids who don't know
anything about they're gonna grow up
they're gonna be 21 and they're gonna be
like
I'm a little old for this Yeet [__] oh
yeah and then they're gonna be posting
them like that no I didn't like on my
gram I said the reality is this
conceptual music that's made with intent
and purpose it's always gonna Outlast
yeah the latter and the reason why is
because these young kids who adapt to
[__] so quickly they're young they don't
have responsibilities they're not going
through real things but as they get
older and they have bills they're going
through real relationships they're not
gonna still want the same microwavable
[__] yeah they need things that get them
through the times and relate them relate
to them during the times that they're
dealing with them who are they going to
turn to the things that they once
criticized and turned a cheat to that
they didn't understand at the time right
and that's why you have the scissors and
the genetic holes and the lizos and the
Kendricks and the J Cole's they Outlast
everybody for sure because it's quality
yeah I mean I always say that because
people are always going to go through
the same troubles tribulations life
experiences over and over they just have
to reach a certain age when it clicks in
and some people hit it earlier than
others but it's gonna click no matter
what it's inevitable